it's totally free what's funny
and i don't know if i can say this i
hope i don't get in trouble for saying
this but
i started this business from a cell
phone in federal prison
so a contraband cell phone and of course
you're not allowed to
have it but what's funny is you know i
got off the bus at big sandy
i went there because i heard there's 59
inmates and 57 of them have phones
some of them have two so i think it's
crazy
first of all you even got to pick the
prison you went to normally you wouldn't
so you tell them you want to go to big
sandy
and then they'll send you to ashland i
didn't want to go to ashland
i was the captain's orderly at pensacola
so i worked in the hallway and
every morning i'm not saying i did get
preferential treatment i would say
because of this
i'm not saying normally would work out
this way because it wouldn't but i went
to my
i did it the right way first i went to
my case manager after i completed the
rdap program i said look i want to do my
new year home transfer which is one of
the perks of completing the program
successfully
and she said well i'm not sending you to
big sandy
but you actually get two picks you get
to give them two places that you want to
go
and after you complete the program
they're supposed to give you one of the
other
usually though to be something you
didn't even ask for it's crazy
so came back she wrote down ashland and
wrote down one other
ashland and and uh morgantown
i don't want she's like these are the
two closest facilities to your house
that's what i'm putting you in for
she didn't give me the opportunity to
pick so i pulled up on the warden
in the chow hall and i said excuse me
and you know and the captain stood
forward patting me down first before i
talked to him
i talked to him i told him the situation
was the name miss pickerel
miss pickerel and i told him what
happened i was like look like i'm not
trying
i'm not trying to throw her under the
bus but you know i completed the program
i've done everything right i've stayed
out of trouble
i thought i could put in two things he's
like you can and i said well according
to her
she's putting me in for what she wants
to put me in for and i don't get the pic
he said i'll have a word with miss
pickerel so then he
talks to my case manager and the next
day she calls me to her office she's
she's livid she's yelling at me i just
stood
there like in shock like wow you know
and she's like why did you go over my
head why did you talk to the
she's mad that she got caught for not
doing her job right
so i wouldn't talk to miss fultz and
interesting and she was the case manager
coordinator she's like the boss of all
the case managers
and you know i would hold her door in
the morning hold her coffee for while
she was coming in her office i was
always in there polishing the brass and
cleaning the mop in the hallways and
stuff
so she was already acquainted with me
and i went and talked to her
and i said i told her the situation with
you know how i told her how everything
went down
and i said is there any way you could
help me to get designated to pick sandy
she said why do you want to go to big
sandy you want to get a cell phone don't
you
it's everybody knows this is enough for
cell phones and i said cell phone prison
it's known for so so uh
so i said no i don't want to get a cell
phone you know that's not my intention
i i just i heard it's a good facility
she said it is a good facility she said
i opened it
i was there for 15 years and she said
you would probably like it there
and i told her how everything went she
went down and talked to the warden for a
couple minutes came back
punched it in the system next thing i
knew designated bsy big sandy kentucky
wow so made it happen
and when i got there as soon as i got
off the bus
uh officer smith interesting that's my
last name so officer smith's
he was walking me through the corridor i
just i was waiting on a ride i shot an
inmate was picking me up to drive me up
to the camp
and uh so he said so if you want to get
a cell phone
anything you need just go talk to
uh this guy named lou big lou he's the
store guy
you can't miss him a big black guy
with a beard he's kind of short he said
he's the store guy so
you just talk to him he'll hook you up
and
so it's it's pretty wild but you know
you play it off like you're not trying
to get a phone but
this kind of phone what kind of phone
was it so there was all kinds of phones
i mean people i saw everything from the
latest iphone to the cheapest android
um i had uh it was an android phone it
was a like a j7 were they smartphones
were they
flip phones no no smartphones for sure
they were i installed tablets
so i i saw everything but uh you know we
would
apple store in there i hope that i'm not
blowing the prison up by saying this i'm
gonna have a lot of people mad at me
but uh then don't worry nobody listens
to this podcast
so except actually mass probation
officer listens to it
oh does he i'm sure mine will too yeah
oh you're still dealing with the
probation officer i don't even think
about that i am
so i actually i've been blessed my
probation officer
is honestly i don't think i could have
got a better probation officer
he's been good to me it's not i've heard
horror stories but he's been nothing but
good to me
really he's been good to me of course
you know he has to show up and drug test
me and stuff like that but
you don't have he doesn't have to worry
about me and it's nice knowing that
like for example a week a couple weeks
ago he sent me a link to a program
uh that the that the united states
patent office is having where they do
pro bono patents
and he was like this might help you in
your business you know he's actually
trying to help me
and you know that that that says a lot
do you have to pay any restitution no
don't no oh yeah you're lucky matt has
to pay a lot of fun like
yeah when there's when it's fraud and
there's like injured parties like when
people have lost money
then you have to pay it back walk over
yeah man he stole all the money from
walkovia
was it wackovia yeah that's before it
was wells fargo
yeah right yeah that's crazy i remember
when that when that acquisition happened
when they changed all of the walkover
buildings over to wells fargo i don't
even remember that i wasn't thinking how
long ago was that
ten years at least yeah it was a while
ago yeah
that's wild i remember what covey was
like blue buildings blue and gray
and then everything changed over to the
the red i heard wells fargo has
more offices than any like more real
estate than any other bank
i i don't know they have make sense they
have more [ __ ] like locations
physical locations that's crazy which i
don't know if that's a good thing or
or a bad thing the way the world's
changing right now
you're you're saying like leaving
females like nobody works is working in
offices anymore
right everything decent everything's
decentralized everyone's working from
home i like that
i like the new normal from that aspect
there's a lot that i don't like
but you know like flying down here uh
wearing a mask the whole time like i'm
so over the masks man
yeah same way like i think like our
immune system is meant to be exposed to
bacteria and viruses and we're supposed
to develop immunity to this stuff
naturally just let it work the way you
know and someone brought it to my
attention the guy i met at the mall
it's so crazy his username freedom
fighter with some numbers on it but
so his username on telegram so you know
he's a freedom
what's this telegram you keep talking
about telegram is an app they have like
groups so you can subscribe to a group
and people post stuff
uh in the group and it it's not a lot of
clutter like you think it's constantly
blowing up your phone
it's not bad but it's like a social
media app
kinda you know it's it's more like
sharing information like there's good
like
altcoin and cryptocurrency conversations
on there like bitcoin bin
there's a bunch of stuff on there where
you can get good information
on on the the up and coming coins that
you should be investing in
you know new opportunities so it's kind
of like clubhouse
clubhouse is great it's awesome you know
just
just tyler actually
talked a lot about clubhouse i
downloaded it a couple months ago and
listened to a few chats that grant
cardone this big on clubhouse
you know really good stuff on there
startups raising money
that talk about how to do it i mean the
information is readily available
it's like linkedin but with audio right
all audio
i think it's brilliant it's just people
trying to find opportunities and meet
new people right
i